would Hamas have attacked Israel if
Trump had been in
power uh I have no reason to think
not
um I mean some ways
Trump looked like a more reliable Ally
maybe
but look at the speeches Biden and Trump
gave in the aftermath of this thing I
mean there's I haven't seen them oh I
mean Biden's I mean correcting for you
know the evidence
of you know geriatric neurological
problems Biden's speech was was just a
full Embrace of our allyship with Israel
and Trump's was this kind of deranged
self-focused criticism of Netanyahu and
I mean it was just it was it was all
about Trump I mean it's uh I mean that
is on brand yeah no but but argument I
think might be sorry to interrupt that a
trump was seen as tougher uh perhaps
more irrational which is not unhelpful
in this sort of situation and also he
worked very hard on the Abraham Accords
right which which would taking the
Middle East some people would argue
towards a healthier Place yeah and I
would agree with that part
um the Abraham Accords I think
uh it's just it's just a non-factor for
me I think it's this is going to H
happen anyway this will continue to
happen it was unsurprising that it
happened the the details of its
happening were profoundly surprising
given what we thought the IDF was was
capable of and and what was unlikely to
you know the specifics were were
surprising but um this will be a
recurring story of Our Lives
until frankly until the Muslim world has
a civil war with itself with its own
extremists this is not it's it's it's
it's not a problem we're going to solve
we need two billion Muslims to figure
out how to deal with their problem of
homegrown extremism in 100
countries yes I hear you I think the
source sorry to needle this but I think
it's important to flesh out I think the
source of this question I may
be hallucinating is you were vehemently
anti-trump and I guess what I think
people are asking
is were you not wrong about that because
there's so many other liabilities with
Trump I mean in fact it's the similarity
to Trump and
trumpism that sha that did much to
shatter Israeli society and seemingly
soften it up for this attack right it's
in so in so far as Netanyahu who's a
hell of a lot smarter than Trump and
more sophisticated than Trump in so far
as he resembles Trump in so far as he
was engineering a similarly populist
eruption of bullshittery and in his own
Society um the divisiveness of all of
that the the untenability of all of that
the the the lack of pragmatism the
taking the eye off the ball of of the
real threats to to Israel um you know so
the similarities there are are are awful
and and in so far as uh we have a trump
and trumpism has a similar effect on our
own Society um it repres represents the
same kind of opportunity cost I mean you
think of all the things we didn't get
done and will not get done for every
moment we spend dealing with the
divisiveness of trumpism and and the
counter reaction from the left I mean
it's just it's just a massive
opportunity cost so no I think it's
there's nothing good e even if you can
find some local instance where Trump was
right about something uh and the
Democrats were wrong I mean he's he's
totally right about the southern border
right I mean so that's a there's no in
my view there's absolutely no defense of
having an indefensible border we should
know who's coming into the country we
should let the people in we want in we
should keep the people out we want to
keep out we should have obviously a sane
and compassionate policy with respect to
refugees build the wall I me yes if the
wall is the best way to to secure that
border then Build That Wall right so
Trump's right about that but he's such
an awful human being and his effect on
our politics is so toxic that we can't
even that that that half of our soci has
to treat that completely same project as
a form of racism because they're
reacting to the the big golem of of
trump so we need other
people even where Trump is right we need
other people quarterbacking those
specific decisions so what you're saying
is you're Pro trumps yeah exactly build
the wall build the wall
exactly l lind's one we've touched on
this but they ask uh what is Eric's take
on the delus on the Deluge of pro Hamas
protests after the most recent attack in
Western countries well I tried to talk
about I think when I was on Rogan
recently maybe on your show I don't
remember there's been a huge uptick in
uh open anti-Semitism and it's right on
schedule I mean I think that if you are
monitoring what I'm monitoring you're
not that surprised by it you're just
you know what we knew is that it it's to
the Bone and so when people talk about
you know black and brown bodies or you
know I don't feel safe like there was a
spade of uh postings about I don't feel
safe as a Muslim you you're like oh cut
it
out it's a radical
anti-semitic ideology of
Revolution and it's
it's on schedule and it's it's terrible
that we've gotten here but in part A lot
of
the well-meaning um left did not
understand that they'd gotten into the
ocean with a revolutionary current
pulling them uh along the beach and they
end up getting out of the water very far
away from their beach towel they're not
anywhere close to being liberal tolerant
um because you in their attempts to say
well black lives matter and we care
about this they didn't notice who they
were affiliating themselves with and uh
hopefully if you've seen a charred body
or severed limbs or shot up Port tootes
um you're making an intelligent decision
about what really matters to you and if
you think uh you know in the occupation
free Palestine go
paragliders uh you're probably really
deep in it I I I you know I I hope that
deprogramming exists for you I hope that
you really think about whether you want
to sanction um rape torture and message
killing and if that's your thing then I
guess well you know where you
are uh John Watson says uh could The
Lads ask Sam what he thinks his old
friend Christopher Hitchens would make
of the current political landscape
particularly with regards to gender
identity which has essentially become a
new
religion I I think he would make exactly
what we have all made of it uh and it
would be a lot of fun to hear him talk
about it but I I think he I don't think
there'd be any daylight between him and
us on that point I don't imagine but
he'd be funnier and more cutting at the
same time it would be a lot of fun yeah
yeah World by wolf asks Eric pick your
dream president and VP for our
times
well it's really hard because I think
that the current political landscape
deforms everyone who enters this I've
watched this with with uh the pressures
put on Tulsi Bernie and uh R uh RFK
Junior
um we keep getting a Fugu sort of
situation where there are lots of parts
of the fish that you like and there's
some partion of the fish that that's
deadly and so we haven't had that I I'm
going to have to cheat on the answer to
this which is the Optics of the first
Obama candidacy is the substance we need
in the white house um but I haven't seen
anyone with the ability to run this
Gauntlet who's
viable and so I I just don't think that
we have a situation in
which
anyone is speaking in real terms I'm I'm
sorry to say it I can't see a single
voice on the viable political
landscape that excites me and the last
thing I was excited about was Obama 1
and uh clearly I ended up buying a
campaign that governed in a very
different form than the one I
expected Big Bob 86 says uh first of all
Sam I'd like to thank you as I've been
quite a fan of yours over the years I
watched many of your discussions and
debates and read and listen to a number
of your books and audio books my
question is this has the change from
religious values underpinning our
society to more secular values actually
panned out the way you thought or hoped
it
would
uh no although I'm not sure the the the
loss of religious subscription is is the
reason I'm sorry what what I'm What I
Hear in that question is that PE that
the moment you lose religious belief
something some religion shaped object is
going to fill that void and I I I don't
actually think that's true but you don't
no you don't see wokeness as a kind of
replacement religion no I mean I think
that's it's
um I it had so it has religious
characteristics right so it is so but uh
first of all some of the people who are
woke are also religious obviously there
it's not a perfect substitute but
um I
think I mean there you know
I it's hard to it's hard to know what to
make of the data and I just know that
you know I'm a I'm the existence proof
and the many people I know are the
existence proof that it's possible to
lose your belief in Santa Claus and not
replace it with something that does all
the work Santa Claus did the day before
right so it's you can you can find you
your meaning and your aspiration and
your
motivation
in in other ways that have that run by a
different logic once you can but as we
were talking about people basically
every but basically everyone I spend a
lot of time with can right okay would
you agree with me that your your
experience and the experience of your
highly selected friendship group I
imagine is not necessarily
representative of the average person
it's true but so then we just have to
admit we're saying which is which rarely
gets done which is uh I don't need these
crazy ideas you don't need these crazy
ideas but the the morons over there are
not going to figure out how to you
deliberately loaded it with the motion
so let's take the motion out there are
but but that's the subtext of being
claim no not necessarily uh it could be
it could be that different people
because of uh many many different things
genetics cultural values
their material circumstances their locus
of control over their own lives right
which as you get wealthier and more
powerful and influential
changes uh some people are able to deal
with the things that religion
traditionally has fulfilled fear of
death meaning purpose Etc that you and
to some extent I and Richard Dawkins I
put the same question to him when we had
him on the show about this some people
are able to to get it from things other
than religion but if you take it away
from other people who are not wired the
way that you are who do not have the
resources that you do who for whatever
reason they not predisposed to that way
of thinking who have a greater fear of
death than you do for those people a set
of traditional beliefs that center
around something that you and I might
agree isn't entirely true or is entirely
untrue you might say is valuable in a
way that it is not for you and your
friends well so what I will admit is
that there are certain cases where
irrational
dogmas cause people to be to behave
better than they otherwise would there
are certainly those cases uh and that's
good except for the fact that there are
other ways to get people to behave in
those same ways that are that are more
valid and scalable and and and have high
more Integrity right so yeah it's
possible to go to subsaharan Africa and
work in a refugee camp because you
believe the creator of the universe
wants you to do it and you're saving
souls for Christ but it's it's also
possible to realize that you just
actually care about a famine in Somalia
or Ethiopia and you want to work with
Doctors Without Borders or whatever and
you're doing that actually based on
caring about human suffering and in a
global sense right so they're just one
code is much better to be running on
your brain than the other um and doesn't
come with the attendant downside of
suddenly throwing this moral error of
like now we're Catholics in subsaharan
Africa and we're teaching the sinfulness
of condom use
uh even when people are dying from AIDS
and condoms is the only way to prevent
them from dying from AIDS um Etc so uh
there are better reasons to be good than
than religion tends to provide but I
would grant you that that religion does
provide those reasons for some people
some of the time my problem with
religion is that it gets the so much
wrong that leads to to unnecessary
conflict and Division and and an
opportunity cost in our society
this is certainly in the 21st century
with all all the opportunities in front
of us and it doesn't get the core parts
right that I would agree still our core
like what are our real spiritual
opportunities like what what is how just
how good could human consciousness be
moment to moment how good can human life
be moment to moment and for that I do
think there is a there there there are
these core experiences at the heart of
religion that gave rise to our religions
perhaps some more than others I mean
again our religions are different
but I do think we need something like a
modern mysteries of elus where uh I mean
I'm so I'm I'm I'm very I'm very mindful
of the the the errors we made in the 60s
around psychedelics but I'm very hopeful
that a Renaissance of in in research and
interest in in psychedelics um could
allow us to make to put certain
experiences certain transformative
experiences and states of Consciousness
in reach for virtually everyone and we
need a cultural context in which to
absorb those epiphanies and talk about
them that doesn't make reference to our
religious sectarianism or at least
doesn't make sectarian reference to our
our Legacy religions if you want to make
eclectic you know small C Catholic
reference to you know just the
storehouse of religious literature
that's great you know there's no problem
taking the good parts even from the
Quran uh to to make sense of those those
experiences but we
just Rel real religious sectarianism I
think has to be a deal breaker at this
point I mean just it can't it's just too
costly so um I think it's good to get
rid of it in so far as we are getting
rid of it in the west that's good and
the fact that these
these minor mon these minor
monstrosities of of things like wokeness
and you know social justice moral panics
I mean even if they're drawing energy
from the the Advent of of a more atheism
and more more secularism
um I think it's a bet I think it's a
price we should pay and and we need to
combat those forms of irrationality as
well right so I spent a lot in recent
years I've spent a lot more time
complaining about wokeness and I've then
I've and you know leftist moral panics
and I have organized religion and it's
it's because it's it's it's really
uh in my in my immediate purview it's
it's been more costly you know I mean
it's V it's been viting our
institutions Eric what would you prefer
physics or
music I have two
questions
well geez there's a tiny amount of
physics that's more beautiful than all
music okay so I'm going to go with that
okay so Mark Greg Sputnik asks what are
the fields away from quantum gravity
that you feel are the most important
path paths for physicists to
pursue
the standard model of particle theory
was revealed to be geometric in the mid
1970s and has been made almost perfectly
geometric by the end of the 80s the
right thing to do is to ask why we have
three generations of fundamental fans
with 16 particles per generation with a
crazy Hig sector with a quartic
potential the accidents that is of why
this particular set of
objects is without question in my mind
the most potent question in all of
physics and we abandoned it more or less
in
1983 when we switched to saying we're
not looking for a unified theory we're
looking to quantize gravity and so we
reinterpreted and in my opinion clearly
misinterpreted what the charge of
physics was and the correct thing to do
is to ask why this particular universe
that we see ourselves confronting rather
than following the path to say what is
the general nature of quantum field
Theory because Quantum field theory was
recently revealed uh like linear algebra
and calculus before it to not have
anything particularly to do with physics
you can't do physics without it but it
turns out that it's a general framework
that governs many more things that have
nothing to do with the physical world in
which we live and so getting out of that
Quantum field Theory uh monomania and
getting out of quantum gravity monomania
and substituting with a question of why
in this particular beautiful universe is
the one in which we
live Charles cbal says does Sam feel the
world is at its closest to World War II
it has been since World War
II I would defer to the the experts who
have really been watching this on that I
think I think it's still I mean you know
last week notwithstanding I think it's
still the opinion of most qualified
people that the Cuban Missile Crisis was
the closest
moment but I'm not saying we're in a
good spot either it's it's I think it's
our n it should be our number one
existential
concern uh followed closely
by uh pandemic engineered or
otherwise sou Joe asks Eric are there
any fundamental questions in physics
which AI could help
resolve
um sure you could search for all
renormalizable field theories uh and try
to do an exhaustive search
um I'm just going to make a cautionary
point I think that the idea of
asking AI to solve your problems with
physics which probably contains more
leverage than any other discipline has
ever had in terms of the power that can
be wielded from Simply understanding
something it's as if you haven't seen a
single science fiction movie to prepare
you this is probably the dumbest consult
I've ever heard in my life I cannot
figure out what we're
doing I I I actually don't understand
that last Point you're saying asking AI
to do discoveries in physics is so
dangerous we shouldn't be doing that or
yes I think
that these are the last AIS that you
could
consider
you know the difference between chat GPT
and what is it chain GPT or where you
have it create the prompts to give you
the
next you're playing around with things
that you don't understand before the
attention is all you need paper you
could make the case that maybe AI is
very very distant I was listening to Sam
in my first meeting first day I met Sam
we did a podcast and Sam's talking about
Ai and you can tell where this is going
he didn't have a time frame I don't
think anybody really understood the
large language model revolution in the
Transformer architecture and I think
you're now so close to something that
could totally surprise you um with
particularly with emergent Behavior
where an AI will learn Bengali um
because it needs to without being told
you should learn Bengali now
um I would be very careful about the
idea that we're going to rely on AI to
advance our knowledge of
physics we'll be back with Sam and Eric
in a minute but first we want to take a
moment to talk about our partners gend
go gend go is a leading crowdfunding
website where thousands of people around
the world raise funds for business
ventures medical expenses personal needs
nonprofits churches and funeral costs on
gend go you can raise money for whatever
you need we've met the people at gendo
and we can tell you that they're
absolutely aligned with trigonometry on
our approach to free speech they don't
just talk the talk they walk the walk
unlike other big tech companies they
like us believe that with openness and
honesty will create more understanding
and ultimately more Harmony in the world
gifs and go is absolutely free to use
with other crowdfunding sites you'll pay
between 5 and 10% of the money you raise
give and go charge no money at all to
use their platform they believe you
should be able to keep all the money you
raise on giv and go you can choose to
raise funds for short or long-term
campaigns whether you're in the USA UK
Australia or anywhere in the world GI
and go supports freedom of speech they
won't cave to the Mob and that's why we
are proud to partner with them starting
a campaign on giv and go is easy and
intuitive go to gio.com today start
raising money for whatever's important
to you and support the people who
support Freedom now back to the
interview uh Ramsey says that it's great
to have you back on the show and respect
for that which is nice um and I think
alluding to the very same point I'll
fight you naked says you have recently
made the decision not to speak to some
people who disagree with you why is that
I'm not sure who he might be thinking of
I mean so there are people who
I would not be inclined to talk to I
think Brett is one of
them let not because they disagree with
me but because I think they've behaved
unethically you like there's
uh no that that if you're thinking of
your brother that's conflating two
things they topics there there topics
that I think it was irresponsible to
debate podcast certainly in the middle
of a a public health emergency right
um
and certain styles of conversation
certain participants that I thought was
just never never going to con Converge
on use a useful document to to export to
to millions of people so I felt it was
irresponsible to have certain
conversations certain ways during the
pandemic there are certain other people
who totally disagree with me on lots of
controversial points who I will talk to
just because I you know it's they there
hasn't been any
um breach of Ethics no matter how much
we disagree always dealt with my side
fairly or my beliefs fairly then there
are people who have gratuitously
misrepresented my my beliefs thinking
they were going to be scoring some kind
of points against me and they were
scoring points against me for Their
audience right and those are people I'm
not inclined to talk to because I just
don't I don't want to reward that kind
of behavior I mean it's certainly
behavior that
I have been fairly careful not to engage
in myself and when whenever I've done it
inadvertently I've apologized for it um
you know I never I never feel like I
need to strawman my opponent or much
less lie about their views in order to
argue against them so um but there's
been a lot of incoming of that sort uh
toward me so there's there's some people
who used to be friends um who yeah would
not be inclined to talk to but there are
other people who to again I'm
not I don't know what I don't know but
like there there are people who I
disagree with a lot but I'll talk to
them I mean like you know Megan Kelly is
somebody who like our politics are not
aligned but she's to my eye she's always
treated
me fairly to a point that has been
uncomfortable for her in front of her
own audience knowing what her audience
wants certainly in the aftermath of the
podcast we did and then the clip that
got exported to you know every every
mind in trumpistan um you know the way
she dealt with that seemed totally fair
and honest and so yeah there's no I've
got no hesitation talking to her and
there's a lot of people on that list and
there's a short list of people who
consciously created clickbait for Their
audience very often with my name in the
title you know Sam Harris just said
something crazy and um then they've used
that clip or some other clip you know
even more ridiculous Clips there was one
clip made by the same person who where
it seemed I was saying or uh you know
the audience was led to believe I was
saying that I wished more kids died
during coid so I could have been proven
right in my in my paranoid views about
Co um so if you're going to do that of
course I'm not going to talk to you and
if you're GNA if you're G to dunk on if
you're going to amplify that and dunk on
that I'm not I'm not inclined to talk to
you s one question I have about that is
could you not I didn't understand why
you didn't try to do something with
bread that was closer to correspondence
chess where you had a right to consult
with experts given that you're not a
biologist right and or medical doctors
and the idea is that you don't have it
live so that you're you know get you get
broadsided but just decide we're going
to have a go back and forth of uh you
know 15 or 20 go rounds and I'll be
Consulting people and you can be
Consulting people let's have the best
version of that it seems to me that you
didn't
for an a non-standard debate so largely
because of the opportunity cost because
of how much you know I would have viewed
that probably as a a month of work to do
responsibly and I see no reason to do it
because your
brother's disappearance down the this
particular rabbit hole is is just it's
not something
that I felt I needed to interact with I
mean I was it was it was getting thrust
in my face so much that I had to I had
to dis interact with it enough to just
to say I had to kind of disavow it but
the fact that he was going to spend a
hundred podcasts in a row worth of his
energy on that topic didn't shouldn't
have meant that I needed and to be
whatever you wanted I mean in other
words even if you didn't end up having a
debate at least if you did that people
would understand
that you wanted to have the Topline
issues adjudicated and I very much agree
that you don't get into a fight or a
debate with somebody who's totally
unethical right because it's too
dangerous well I I just think I mean for
me I I recently released a podcast which
I think you probably heard this like my
postmortem on coid um you know solo
podcast and for me the you know the the
airplane analogy I use there covers the
sort of the the the framing that works
for me which is
you know there are moments where you
want
to really drill down yeah you want
everyone to do their own research and
sunlight is the best disinfectant and
let's just talk about everything for as
long as it takes and there are moments
when you really don't want to do that
where it's dysfunctional to do that
where other harms follow upon doing that
and you know the analogy for me that
covers it is that it's like when you're
getting on an airplane you know or much
less when you're when you're at 30 ,000
ft on an airplane there are lots of
things you don't want to talk about and
and debate you don't want you don't want
someone to take a poll of the passengers
and you know ask questions like do we
still trust the pilots or or you know
how do we know those those engines were
engineered correctly and you don't want
you don't want someone pulling up an
episode of The Joe Rogan podcast which
said which has an engineer who says that
he designed the engines on the plane
that you're now on and it was always
just supposed to be a concept engine and
it's irresponsible that they're being
flown and and and like just how much
energy do you want to give that when the
reality of your situation
is you have to actually Land This Plane
safely right there's no alternative but
to do that right um and so this engine
you actually have to rely on this engine
right now and what I what I thought at
the time and I still think is that
uh we were all essentially in a plane at
30,000 ft together and we we were having
to figure out how to land that
particular plane given the engines we
had and we need so we you know we needed
a we needed a CDC that we could trust we
needed an FDA that we could trust we
needed to trust the government messaging
with respect to what was actually
happening in the world and well Sam
those are two very different points no I
agree with you that we needed a CDC
ET in so far as we didn't have that that
is something we need to deal with what I
what I feared and fear is that what has
happened is there's been such an erosion
of trust in in
institutions and the layer of of
conversation we're having about about
this in the aftermath on social media is
so dysfunctional and so and so
amplifying of mistrust right and
misinformation and
disinformation that
um we're
just we're in a very bad spot to reboot
from I mean so so yeah yes I mean
absolutely we have to fix our
institutions are they as bad as your
brother thinks they are no way
absolutely not right so I think he is a
you know uh he's just running a
conspiratorial operation that I think is
is uh producing a lot of Errors of
thinking on his part um and that's why I
felt like I didn't have to interact with
it much but is is there a problem is he
is he right about some things of course
is he going to is he going to detect
real conspiracies and and perverse
incentives uh sooner than than I will
maybe because he's constantly looking
for those things uh but I would agree
that you know yeah stepping back from
the precipice of of you know it's all
all the time all conspiracies
are true all the time everyone's evil
everyone ined no no no I'm just that's
that's the cartoon version stepping way
back from there yes we have to we have
to we have to align incentives we need a
you know a drug Discovery regime that
actually discovers good drugs and
doesn't release bad ones um we need all
that and I didn't see us hashing it out
in the middle of an emergency on
podcasts with obviously
weird people like some of the people
your brother and and Joe
platformed I didn't see that as the
method I understand and uh we actually
said we would finish now so we'll finish
all I'll say from my perspective is that
I think that heated moment is now over
and I always hate good people
disagreeing and falling out I hated what
happened I'll say this in this is true
of both me and Francis we hated what
happened with you after the interview
with us and I said this to you in an
email uh the person who clipped that is
not a good person right so but so just
to drill down on this the reason why I'm
sitting with you here is because I
perceived you guys to be totally ethical
in how you handle that moment and it was
a conflict I mean that moment worked to
the massive advantage of your podcast I
mean it brought immense attention to
your
podcast at the absolute reputational
cost of meh right of center right so
like a right of Center that was a
complete just witch burning of me but I
saw the way you guys handled it and I
have no problem with you guys I've never
had a problem with you guys so
um so that's why we're talking but Brett
Amplified I forget this guy's name but
whoever the guy who made made that clip
and I think he made the other clip I was
talking about is it Jack poob no it's no
let I don't even want to give this guy
attention he's not he's a pure I mean
whoever he is in reality
Twitter has made him a psychopath right
and your brother locked arms with him
just without caveat and Amplified him as
just this just citizen journalist who
has gone to school on all the important
topics and found all the errors in my
podcast and those clips were just it
just P it was a pure smear Campaign
which youru which your brother energized
complely AG with you so that's and
that's where we that's where I am you
know there's no I I never did the
analogous thing to your brother and I
wouldn't and I'm not sure where your
brother's head is now where he can can
rationalize what happened there but he's
his buddies with a with a complete
lunatic and um what was amazing I mean
this is a much longer conversation about
how weird social media has made
everything but like when that 20 Megaton
you know faux PA was going off in you
know in your very much in your world and
blowing up your podcast in my like
literally
nothing was happening in my world and in
the places I care about nothing was
happening and yet that was the first
moment I could see how my interaction
with Twitter was just giving me you know
Pure Noise that was pretending to be
signal right now this and and I it's not
that there was no signal there and this
is something you and I have talked about
a lot you know offline which is um you
know there's I I I basically based on
how I've designed my life and how I've
designed my my business I have the the
luxury of being of of not caring about
certain things happening to me online um
but this was a case where it was just
like I was my life was like air gapped
from just like a mushroom cloud you know
and it was it it was just so enormous
and
so non-existent where I live that I just
thought okay this is
a this is a hallucination machine you
know and I've spent 12 years staring
into it and it's
um uh it's not worth it so it's like the
so the the outcome you the proximate
cause of my getting off Twitter was the
aftermath of you know having gone on
your podcast and it's been you
know apart from the occasional feeling
of like in this last week
being on the sidelines of a of a
necessary
conversation uh which when I look 15
minutes later I realized okay this is
still just a digital sewer that I don't
need to be contributing to I have other
places to to make noise like you know on
this podcast
um it has been like I mean as you we
were talking before we we started
rolling it has just been I'm embarrassed
at what a upgrade of my life it's been
not to be on Twitter for the last 10
months or whatever it's been you're
welcome I no I mean it's it's completely
inadvertent but it's it's like it's it's
been such a gift to not be segmenting my
life in you know dozens of times a day
looking at at the at completely I
mean it's
uh I mean like it's like waking it's
like waking up from a dream where you
just can't even figure out how you got
that confused you know and um it's so
yeah uh yeah thank you you gave me
meditation thank you for the absolute
chaos you you dropped into my you gave
me meditation and I got you off Twitter
yeah Fair exchange it remains to be seen
which is a bigger influence because it
was it was enormous all I wanted to say
Sam is I think it was a very heated
moment the way people talk especially
online encourages fighting encourages
misunderstanding miscommunication Etc I
think you're a great person I understand
you have your concerns about the way
Brett communicated about Co he's also a
great person as a human being he's and I
can tell you this from personal
experience because I've I gave Brett a
piece of very unhelpful information to
him that I gave to lots of other people
that would require him to take an
ethical but very difficult decision and
he was the only person out of dozens
that did so I hope that one day there is
a world where you're sitting around a
table you're sitting on a show like or
wherever it is that there is
understanding and Reconciliation I
really hope for that that's all I'm
saying it may never happen and it's
entirely up to you and well to be clear
I I think I think Brett is I've always
thought Brett was a a an extremely
ethical person I don't know how he got
so turned around as to think that this
jackass he's aligned with is a that his
ethics are well served by by amplifying
that kind of contribution to this
conversation I think that you're not if
I may because I have the same problem
you have with this person um but but
your brother but strangely your brother
doesn't have the same problem with that
with that person well I was going to get
to that which
is I think that Brett went through a
catastrophe over Co where he tried to
make simple points things like vaccines
change adaptive
Landscapes with respect to Fitness
computations that is a non-controversial
point um and to
become I watch the system say oh we have
a problem somebody's disagreeing with
the
narrative our beautiful Public Health uh
narrative is above your pay grade the
only way to get you out of this is to go
after you as a human to say you're
you're promoting junk science you're a
Charlotte and you're a grifter etc etc
and
Brett found himself suddenly you know
because he
misstruck on every point which I don't
think he was um I knew that that was
going to end in Disaster by his
structuring of it it did end in disaster
and what you're watching is somebody
trying to claw back their reputation
after having the full force of the US
federal
government um find its way you know into
the public sphere as we saw in the
Twitter files that you know government
is very keen that its Master
narratives uh not be taken down and so
when you see you know I don't know is it
this CDC talking about horse Ste you
know come on you're not a horse don't
take horse paste
um he probably felt that he had very few
friends and allies who would fight side
shoulder Tosh shoulder and so in part as
the guy who popularized audience uh
capture as a something we all need to
worry about I can also tell you that
isolation and lack of friendship is a
huge problem and one of the things that
I've been really upset about is we have
a very small number of people who are
strong enough to try to think in public
at the moment and we can't afford
this infighting I agree and I I
personally think that you know I've said
to Brett Heather should never have gone
after you for Trump derangements
syndrome Brett should never have joined
in you shouldn't have returned fire but
you did he did whatever that's the
beginning of this thing and you know now
you've got this super important thing
that you should figure out a way of
offering something so that if and when
Brett
declines to do your form of a structured
debate you're not the
one who's denying them the opportunity
I'll just be very clear about it there
was a point where Sher re-recorded the
song I've Got You Babe with beas and
Butthead and she was so angry at Sunny
Bono that she stuck it to Sunny Bono in
the re-recording of that song the only
problem is that that song was many
people's wedding songs that was people's
song where they got together and they
got engaged who knows what it wasn't her
song necessarily to do with as she saw
fit because it was it was part of too
many people's lives and I believe that
in part one of the things that we owe
our world is that we work this out
if we have the opportunity to work this
out
and you know quite honestly Brett has
gone down a hole in my opinion um
because he's been forced to go down a
hole so if that's the question that
you're asking I think that the issue is
isolation and that's and just to close
it out I made this very clear statement
that if I find that any of my friends
are guilty of murder May am rape who
knows what as bad as it can be I'm not
going to be abandoning my friends and
why am I why do I make that statement
one because isolated people are
dangerous we don't it's not safe to have
isolated people so you need to have
friends who keep showing up even when
you're in prison the other thing about
it is is that then it becomes very easy
to get us to move away from each other
and you know the one thing Sam that I
can tell you is is that a lot of your
friends on the sort of the right hand
side of of whatever this milu that we're
a part of it's pretty clear everybody
wants to be in contact with you they
want a better relationship every you
know everybody says I miss Sam and
whatever confusions they have you can
probably find that people want to want
to figure this out I mean I think people
view you as a very singular and
important voice
and I think it's a it's a mistake to
have all this Integrity where we stop
speaking to friends because they're all
now beyond the pit
this time has been so confusing that
everybody has made terrible terrible
mistakes and the best of us have made
fewer mistakes than others but nobody
has gotten way Scot free it's just the
quality of information we've been lied
to from too many different sources and
we don't have any institutions into
which we can Retreat and I I just I
think it would be a good idea for what's
coming given what we've just seen in the
last week to try to figure out how to
how to get back yeah I mean not to air
all of our dirty laundry in public
public but to air some of it in public
um I mean all of the there's there's not
a general algorithm for this or you know
it's just a this is dependent on the
specifics of a relationship and the spe
specifics of a person's behavior and
there are people
who
um I still don't understand where their
heads are at and I can't follow them
down the rabbit hole but there's know I
don't perceive any interpersonal problem
between me and that person BEC and again
I don't know what I don't know people
are again they're captured by their own
audience they've got thousands of hours
of audio that they're putting out there
and I don't know what they've said about
me but for instance I said something
about our friend Majed on Josh zep's
podcast that uh I regretted because I
sort of I got sort of got walked into it
and I said you like he was telling me
how crazy Majed was and you know you
know I I haven't F maj's gotten very
conspiratorial and it's all planemic and
it's all like I I don't agree with any
of it but I said
something you know however subtly
disparaging of Majid's whole project
and the problem the ethical problem was
I had never personally reach I had never
had a personal communication with maid
trying to figure out where his head was
at um so yeah I so I apologized to Ma I
went on Ma's podcast and apologized to
him talk to him for an hour about a lot
of stuff that I still don't agree with
you know I I can't explain where maj's
gone and it's kind of similar to where
where your brother went um but I do
perceive a difference between people who
like
they're listen if I have if I if if I
have misrepresented anyone's position
about anything to their reputational
detriment I'm just I want I apologize
for it and like I I do it with with
truly Bad actors I mean like Glenn
Greenwald who's just you know does not
have an ethical bone in his body uh
though though every bone is in fact
sanctimonious and pretending to be
ethical this is a guy who when when I
was 10% wrong about what whatever his
stated view was I apologize publicly on
my podcast right where where every word
out of his mouth about me from him is a
lie or Hal truth calculated to paint me
as a as a dangerous Maniac so it's like
you know it's it's something that all I
can do is be careful and honest on my
side but I have to notice when people
even some former friends are treating
me uh with with zero integrity and and
they see absolutely nothing either they
think it's a symmetrical relationship
like we both got this sort of bad unless
just bury the hatchet but they're not
seeing what they did so in the absence
of Brett's attack poodle like the attack
poodle went
away his his endorsement of the ATT the
attack poodle went away I don't care I
don't care about the poodle I care about
okay assume theendorsement of the attack
poodle one totally different situation
interesting
totally I'm glad we had this
conversation I respect you both
immensely and Brett uh I don't agree
with everything any of you say a lot of
the time right that's how we are we're
human beings so I really hope there's a
world in which that particular thing
gets patched up and lots of other things
get patched up the pandemic was it sent
everybody mental MH it just did
we have to accept that everybody in some
way or another I hope we can get through
it I thank you both uh for coming uh for
having this conversation we appreciate
you both yeah and uh let's hope this one
goes viral for the right reasons yeah
yeah inshah yeah wait for the clips yeah
thanks guys thank you
[Music]
guys